on a souhaité participer massivement
avec les régions de france au fonds de
solidarité état région qui s'élève
maintenant à 1 milliards 7 et même
l'état annoncée de l'avantagé de mon
temps donc là à jour y contribue à
hauteur de 30% sa peu près 80 millions
d'euros que la région mais sur ce fond
pour les très petites entreprises les
commerces les artisans qui ont contenu
une baisse de chiffre d'affaires d'au
moins 50%
on s'est beaucoup battu pour que ce
chiffre de 50% soit considérée par 70
pourtant comme le départ donc à une
première vague l'assaillait de deux
demandes satisfaites d'ailleurs
j'encourage vraiment les lignes on a
continué à postuler jusqu'au 30 avril à
tête première vague du fonds de
solidarité parce qu'on pourrait faire un
petit peu mieux je pense vu les
difficultés vous pouvez toucher dans ces
cas-là un chèque qui va jusqu'à 1500
euros
et donc là les régions vont se charger
de la deuxième vague de ce fonds de
solidarité où on peut aller jusqu'à des
montants un peu plus élevée jusqu'à 2000
euros voire 5000 euros et prendre en
charge une partie des loyers dans des
cas très précis tu donc cette phase est
ouverte effectivement le 15 avril et va
se poursuivre mais la première est
encore ouverte
il faut vraiment j'encourage vraiment
nos petits commerçants nos tpe
yvelinoise à y postuler au maximum
il est plusieurs actions de la région
tout d'abord nous avons débloqué 1 sont
d'équipement de nos médecins libéraux
infirmières libérales sages femmes
libérales également les pharmacies un
fonds de 10 millions d'euros pour
s'équiper par exemple un médecin qui
veut faire de la télé médecine qui a
besoin d'acheter un ordinateur avec
webcam d du matériel stérile bien
évidemment et caetera et donc on l'a
décidé d'ouvrir aux pharmacies on voit
beaucoup dans nos pharmacies des pecci
glace la région peu les rembourser sur
facture il ya aussi une énorme opération
de distribution de masques par la région
on a été plutôt réactif au tout début de
cette crise pour commander massivement
des masques via nos relations franco
chinoises notamment on en a commandé 30
millions d'euros il y en a plus de 10
millions d'euros qui ont eu 10 millions
pas donc qui ont été distribués alors en
priorité aux personnels soignants un
tiers à peu près à la rs aux hôpitaux
un deuxième tiers au maire et au
département à hauteur de 20 % de leur
population notamment pour les ehpad
également tout le personnel qui les
policiers municipaux par exemple ils
sont en contact avec la population les
personnes qui ramassent des ordures etc
les résidences qui accueille des
personnes handicapées est là maintenant
on le décline également vers l'activité
économique on va commencer très
prochainement peut-être demain une
opération pour équiper les commerçants
qui sont restés ouverts
les très petites entreprises on a fait
la semaine là toutes les pharmacies
patrie il ya des besoins et d'un qui ne
sont pas satisfaits
paul ellis est en tout cas ce qui est
prévu de la part la région c'est
d'équipé évidemment tous nos agents en
masque déjà dans un premier temps
sachant que l'éducation nationale doit
se charger d'équiper les professeurs et
les élèves
donc on attend vraiment avec impatience
que va annoncer le premier ministre en
tout cas de notre côté nous serons prêts
équipe évidemment nos agents en masque
par ailleurs vous savez que il en
septembre dernier la région a fait une à
l'équipement à proposer un équipement
lycée en matériel informatique
la moitié des lycéens qui ont choisi
cette option du numérique et donc c'est
vrai que ça nous permet d'avoir une
reprise peut-être vraiment transitoire
et graduées puisqu'il ya une possibilité
encore une fois de le faire à distance